Natto is a traditional Japanese food made from fermented soybeans.
Studies have indicated vast health benefits...
...from the consumption of this unique breakfast dish.
Okay.
Alright.
It looks innocent.
Is it bugs?
Oh, gross!
I hope that's cheese.
Oh, it does not taste good.
This tastes like rotten beans.
Bitter, definitely.
Peanut poop.
And it tastes like it's fermented, but it's not bad.
I cannot possibly say enough horrible things about it.
Many Southeast Asians regard durian as the king of fruits.
Its most distinctive feature is its powerful aroma,...
...making it a difficult delicacy to find in stores and restaurants.
Oh my god!
It smells like rotten fruit.
So we're done, right?
We don't have to eat it, we've smelled it, so we're good.
It's the same color as this tablecloth.
This is not a pretty tablecloth.
To the left.
To the left!
Oh god, he doesn't like it.
Now I'm scared.
It tastes good, right?
No.
The taste is not as bad as the smell,...
...but it is not a good taste.
I'm telling you, it's mango mixed with garlic.
I like mango and I like garlic.